et une étape dans bonjour je dirais un
procès ce qui processus qui est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus étendu le pape
françois a réitéré sa demande de pardon
envers les peuples autochtones et les
survivants des pensionnats mais les
demandes d'actions concrètes de mer je
pense que si d'importants que
reconnaître en partie le par françois le
feu hier dans ses parents le reconnaître
le concours de l'église catholique dans
un vaste projet vraiment d'éradiquer nos
cultures et nos peuples ultime ans l'une
des premières étapes dans la guérison
des communautés autochtones c'est
l'accès aux archives des communautés
religieuses
à trouver l'information
une autre demande phare des
représentants autochtones au pays et la
révocation des bulles papales qui ont
défini la doctrine de la découverte au
milieu du 15e siècle et qui ont accordé
aux colonisateurs le droit d'attaquer de
capturer et de soumettre les peuples
autochtones qu'il rencontrait sens
évidemment complètement complètement
faussé l'histoire complètement enfoncé
il délier
finalement
la présence de nos peuples autre geste
symbolique attendu le retour d'artefacts
et d'objets autochtone détenu par le
vatican et les communautés religieuses
quincé les communautés autochtones
elle-même qui possède les artefacts qui
proviennent de leurs propres communautés
de leurs propres ancêtres mais à ce
moment là ils peuvent eux mêmes créé
leur propre narratif pour présenter
leurs histoires leurs propres histoires
au public la réappropriation de leur
patrimoine par les premières nations
leur permettrait aussi de rebâtir des
savoirs qui ont été perdus pour ces gens
là ça peut être un objet qui est encore
vivant pique une importance très grande
pour leur communauté il n'est pas encore
possible de dire si l'église accédera un
jour à ses demandes mais le processus de
réappropriation lui est bien entamée
c'est le moment aussi pour que l'église
elle-même plus respectés justement cette
réappropriation identitaire et
culturelle et spirituelle de l'ensemble
de nos peuples ici flavie sauvage ou
radio canada québec